How does it feel to be viewed as a
father figure by many people who grew up
without one?
Well,
I think it's an unbelievable honor.
How's that?
And that is really what I think.
It's a tremendous honor and I'm doing
absolutely everything I can to be worthy
of that.
And I would like to say to all the
people out there who grew up without a
father,
that's really too bad because you need a
father there to encourage you.
That's what fathers do,
is they encourage,
they help make you courageous,
and if I can help people develop the
capacity to be courageous and to learn
to tell the truth and to be responsible,
then that's great.
I,
I can't imagine a better outcome for me.
And so if people are willing to help me
play that role and to use what I've been
teaching,
to guide them in that manner,
then hooray.
I couldn't possibly imagine a better
outcome than that.
So.